the film begins in a restaurant in
moscow an army serviceman oleg is on a
date with his girlfriend alina engaging
in a flirtatious conversation the couple
alongside the rest of the world is
living a normal day until suddenly the
lights everywhere start to flicker an
airplane stops working mid-air falling
to its doom followed by a worldwide
blackout the entire world except for the
area around moscow parts of belarus
ukraine and finland is plunged into
darkness people in the white areas watch
the news in astonishment as the reporter
describes the situation of the rest of
the world communication with the dark
countries is halted leaving no immediate
way to figure out what the people of
those areas are going through people
assume they are under a terrorist attack
but no one knows for sure what caused
the blackout eventually the dark area is
named the quarantine zone and the areas
with light are named the circle of life
the government sends several drones into
the quarantine zone but they
mysteriously disappear leaving them no
options but to send an army to
investigate as soon as they land the
soldiers are met with a terrifying truth
everyone on the dark side died on the
spot as soon as the blackout occurred
not just humans but animals like fish
cats and even butterflies are dead not
the butterflies one team is inspecting
an apartment when someone attacks a
soldier the person runs away after
jumping off a tall building this means
that not all living things are dead but
the sudden attack remains unexplained a
month passes in similar fashion but the
government sees no progress in their
research they are still oblivious to
what caused the blackout and the deaths
all former soldiers are drafted to the
research teams including the second
protagonist yuri he took a break from
work to look after his mother with
dementia because of the draft he
reluctantly has to leave her with the
next door neighbors hoping she will be
fine until he returns the following day
a new batch of soldiers arrive at their
post lieutenant marina reveals that the
forensic reports of the quarantine zone
dead bodies have just been published it
says the cause of the death is
neurotoxin poisoning produced by the
body itself this means the people were
killed because something triggered their
bodies to produce the toxin abnormally
oleg and his girlfriend elena are at
their post getting ready to deploy to a
quarantine zone for research however
their plan is interrupted by the sudden
ringing of alarms the radar shows that
something massive is coming their way
from the forest the soldiers have no
view of the enemy so they settle on
firing in random directions the scene
cuts to the next morning and we finally
get to see the chaos in broad daylight
the attackers were wild bears who killed
and devoured many of the soldiers and
wreaked havoc on the base the incident
is devastating but also strange because
the bears seemed to have attacked
strategically in another part of the
city a man named sasha is hospitalized
since the blackout occurred something
strange has been happening to sasha as
he sees vivid dreams and hears voices in
his head the morning after the attack
sasha feels uneasy almost as if he can
feel the soldiers fear when they fought
the bears he is then approached by a man
named zhenya who claims to be his ally
he reveals that many people are still
alive in the quarantine zones but are
being controlled by someone sasha is
also connected to their minds because he
was at the border of the circle of life
when the blackout occurred this explains
his dreams and also the bear attack
which was an elaborate plan devised by
the person who is controlling everything
zhenya doesn't disclose how he knows all
of this which causes sasha to panic he
calls the guards but finds out he has
been talking to zhenya in his mind and
he is not physically present in the room
ghosts blackouts and bears oh my
sorry that was a stupid joke meanwhile
in the army base multiple teams of
soldiers set off for different parts of
the quarantined zones for their
respective missions a few hours later
the first team reaches a quarantined
city where the plane had crashed to
their surprise they are welcomed by the
surviving humans who are now a puppet to
someone else they are waiting with tanks
arms and ammunition ready to fight the
soldiers soldier yuri and the second
team are with a press reporter named
olia they reach a town safely where they
have to establish an observation camp
for the next few days meanwhile oleg is
with group three entering a city called
kirov a few days pass and the soldiers
continue keeping watch in their
respective areas then one day a man
named ide approaches sasha and reveals
himself to be a humanoid alien he wants
to use sasha's psychic abilities to find
the perpetrator of the blackout who is
none other than ide's brother raw seems
like sasha is hallucinating [ __ ] again
the lieutenant catches eyed and arrests
them after he promises to explain
everything he knows about the blackout a
while later everyone is in the
interrogation room waiting for ide to
speak he starts by revealing that he and
his people are natives of a planet in a
different galaxy they never age after a
certain point and cannot die of natural
causes until someone kills them when
their planet's sun died they had to
relocate to a better one with a younger
son they chose the earth and sent ide
and his brother raw to the planet to
make it ready by the time everyone else
arrives on a bigger ship two hundred
thousand years ago when ide and raw came
to the earth humans used to possess
psionic powers and could use telepathy
and psychosis this is how they created
pyramids and other unexplained
infrastructures of the world such powers
could be a problem for id's kind when
they came to earth so raw and i'd used a
bio weapon to make the power of psionic
disappear from humans it was the first
step taken to make the earth suitable
for aliens but now raw wants to wipe out
the entire human race so his people
would have the planet to themselves he
caused the blackout and the deaths of
several to put his plan into action his
next step is to use the surviving humans
to fight the people inside the circle of
heaven since he can control them easily
the lieutenant finds it hard to believe
but she has no room to distrust them
after what they have faced in the past
month the most concerning part is that
the aliens are arriving on earth in two
days which means they only have 48 hours
to defeat raw while the officials
discuss their next step oleg and his
group catch a kid trying to collect food
from a store initially they feel
sympathetic and help him but then raw
takes control of the boy and makes him
attack the soldiers they have to
reluctantly shoot him dead and report
the situation to the lieutenant however
this is only the start of the fight when
it gets dark thousands of raw's puppets
from the quarantined zone attack all
three army posts giving rise to a battle
for colonization yuri and his team are
heavily outnumbered so they send a flare
signal to the base asking for
reinforcements the commander gets the
soldiers ready when suddenly the sky
lights up because of flare signals
coming from all directions the entirety
of surviving humans have been
outnumbered making their loss seem
imminent now their only hope is eyed and
fortunately he is willing to help he
tells the lieutenant that they have to
locate raw with sasha's help only when
his brother is stopped i'd can control
the people attacking the soldiers the
lieutenant brings ide and his human
associate genia to the army base where
they have to find sasha and help him
locate raw in the meantime yuri's team
is ambushed to the ground and his fellow
soldiers are killed one after another at
last only two survivors remain him and
olia they have to find another group if
they wish to stay alive hence they get
on a vehicle and make their way to
oleg's team elsewhere eid is helping
sasha focus so they can figure out where
raw is located after trying for a while
sasha finally sees him on top of a
skyscraper in kirov controlling the
human puppets i'd help sasha calm down
and suggests they quickly leave for
kirov it is also the place where oleg is
stationed and where olya and yuri are
headed ide and the team are preparing to
leave when they are informed that the
puppets have attacked the circle of life
as well not wasting more time i'd the
lieutenant and her soldiers leave for
kirov sasha is asked to stay at the base
because his life must not be put at risk
on their way to kirov ide reveals that
he doesn't care about sasha's life he
asked the guy to stay back because raw
could track his location which would
mean trouble for all of them as he had
predicted raw finds sasha's location
resulting in several missiles being
launched at the base the soldiers try
their best to fight back but eventually
the entire base is destroyed and
everyone inside is killed the lieutenant
loses her mind and blames eyed for
killing her people i'd on the other hand
claims that this was the only way they
could run away from raw without him
becoming suspicious the soldier's death
was inevitable and frankly necessary to
save humanity the following morning yuri
and olia find oleg's team and a while
later the lieutenant and her group also
join the soldiers are told everything
about ide and the attack on the circle
of life this means that they are the
only humans alive on earth and they have
to stop raw to prevent humanity's
extinction they do not waste more time
before making their way to the
skyscraper where the villain is but on
the way their tanks are attacked by a
massive crowd of human puppets one man
jumps on a vehicle with an explosive and
initiates the battle the soldiers remain
inside the tank and fire at the crowd in
front of them they do not stop so the
enemy won't get a chance to climb the
tanks and eventually reach the
skyscraper the commander and his
soldiers decide to remain at the bottom
of the building to deflect the enemy
while the others climb upstairs in a
final showdown yuri and i'd come face to
face with raw yuri runs to attack him
but raw is much stronger he instead
faces a better opponent his brother aide
they fight an intense battle both as
good as each other meanwhile the
commander is struggling to hold off the
puppets when most of his soldiers have
died they are attacked by a vehicle
filled with explosives it causes an
explosion resulting in the deaths of all
soldiers the puppets are now free to
enter the building to their master's aid
raw figures out what is going on
downstairs but it distracts him giving
eyed a chance to land a fatal attack he
rips out a device from ra's chest and
thrusts a grenade into it killing his
brother at last after his death eyed
gains full control over the puppets and
kills them at once now the only humans
alive are yuri oleg the lieutenant olya
alina and jenya they do not feel the joy
of victory as billions of dead bodies
lie all around ide finally reveals that
humans are irrational beings with no
love and compassion even when they show
mercy they will choose a path of
violence one day or the other this is
why raw wanted to end them as a species
and ensure his people's safety they've
clearly demonstrated that they're not
violent at all however i'd has a
different motive he wants to be god and
craves absolute power he could have
warned people long ago about the
blackout but he only came into action
after it happened this is because he
wanted humans to die so they know his
importance and see him as their messiah
an enraged lieutenant holds him at
gunpoint accusing him of killing
billions just for his fantasy before she
shoots zhenya runs at ide with a knife
eid positions himself away from both of
them just in time for zhenya to stab the
lieutenant she is killed in the incident
ide turns himself into oleg's father to
confuse him but jenya sees through his
plan this time he throws him from the
roof dying with him in the fall now the
only people alive are an injured yuri
oleg olya and elena everything falls
silent as they watch an alien spaceship
land on earth the door to the ship opens
and they patiently wait for the invaders
but to their surprise no one comes out
they decide to go inside themselves and
find thousands of aliens sleeping in
cryocapsules they're about to wake up in
a few minutes so the group starts
destroying their oxygen supply to kill
them at last we're dead anyway they say
may as well commit genocide however when
they get to the children's section they
cannot bring themselves to kill the
innocent kids in the last scene hundreds
of alien children come out of the
capsule ready to explore their new home
without parents or guidance of any kind
real nice subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching